m
après avoir travaillé huit ans aux
espaces verts du département marie
hélène robert a décidé de se reconvertir
depuis deux ans un des chefs d'equipe au
service des routes départementales entre
salazie et saint-andré marie hélène et
son équipe interviennent au quotidien au
service des usagers de la route à c'est
un bon mexique c'est un beau métier
j'aime bien ce que je fais comment fait
dire ça à la sécurité des routes et
c'est important parce que tout le monde
prend la route pour aller travailler
pour aller pique nique et pour faire
bonne chose donc c'est important donc
cédera c'est ça m'a motivé pour faire ce
travail
voilà apporter un peu de mots de mon
savoir pour comment pour satisfaire les
gens marie-hélène dirige une équipe de
vingt agents l'entretien des routes
un milieu essentiellement masculin dans
lequel la chef d'equipe a dû s'imposer
une femme comme moi et me mais voilà
mais maintenant je pense que ça s'est
bien passé
voilà il m'écoute j'ai une bonne équipe
wall ag j'ai des anciens qui savent déjà
le travail là je pense que j'ai j'ai
désormais une équipe anciennes voilà
donc et moi prix aussi donc on a fait
quand même des réunions pour voilà un
mot beaucoup et difficile
son secret pour s'intégrer se faire
respecter et son implication
marie-hélène ne se contente pas de
donner des ordres chaque jour elle est
sur le terrain avec son équipe je suis
là je viens voir mon équipe toujours
pour savoir si ça va
et crimes en quelque chose moi je pense
que c'est important quand la présence
était pourtant pas rester dans un bureau
voilà je participe avec mon équipe j'ai
suis avec nick
malgré quelques réticences au départ les
vingt agents routiers ne voient que des
avantages à avoir une femme comme cette
équipe ça ça apporte beaucoup parce que
des femmes quand tu as des hommes c'est
pas facilement là quand tu as une chef
si ça ne serait plus facile à parler de
dire ce qu'ils voient pas et elle aussi
à l'escroc prend la femme avant tout
c'est une maman on va dire voilà c'est
ça ces salles qui le petit puisqu'il à
quoi l'on nous colle encore n'est pas
mais mis à part cela comprend mieux les
hommes de bétonner avait company men
plus tôt toutes deux sens aux comédiens
pour moi ça me dérange pas c'est une
dame qui divise
moi je pense qu'il ya un peu de tension
c'est pour la direction du service des
routes marie-hélène dispose de
nombreuses qualités nécessaires à ce
poste
cependant placé une femme responsable de
brigades dans ce domaine n'était pas
sans risque un pari audacieux alors
marie-hélène on l'a découvert à
l'entretien pour le recrutement sur ce
poste de responsable de brigades de
saint paul et saint nazaire et on a vu
arriver une femme pleine de
détermination avec beaucoup d'envié peu
de compétences dans les routes mais une
envie débordante la rayon de soleil
maintenant mais je crois deux en un an
et demi ou deux ans après ça fait deux
ans qu'elle est en poche je crois
et vraiment je crois qu'on a réussi ce
pari un pari réussi également pour marie
hélène qui a su s'imposer dans la
douceur tout en restant ferme dans ce
milieu d'hommes